in another sign of global progress some
government agencies in one country are
no longer using the term
shark attacks they say it's a
stigmatizing phrase
that unfairly prejudices people against
these subsurface carnivores
instead officials are referring to shark
attacks as or quoting now
negative interactions like when a great
white chews off your leg it's a negative
interaction australia's department of
primary industries just announced that
change
one university of sydney researcher said
the move is appropriate because
most shark attacks are more like small
bites than actual
attacks so how to assess this well dave
portnoy is most famous for starting the
sports site bar stool and is an
online gaming mogul but he's also and if
you knew this
a renowned shark expert in fact he's the
author of the book
sharks have feelings too so it's to dave
portnoy we go
to understand this change dave portney
thanks so much for coming on tonight
so how negative an interaction is a
shark attack would you say
i mean it's really negative but it's
negative for the shark you're in his
territory
he's he lives in the water humans don't
belong in the water
so a shark is minding his own business
and a human wade it would be like a
stranger walking into your house
it's traumatizing and it's negative for
the shark
well that's a completely different
perspective that most americans don't
have they imagine for some reason that
they can kind of
wade into the ocean without getting
eaten but you're saying
that's a violation of the territorial
integrity of sharks
i equate it to me my my domains you know
social social media and twitter and i i
swim around and when somebody doesn't
know anything about me and bumps into me
and i bite him they say they were
attacked
but you came into my house into my
territory if you look at the numbers
uh what there's 10 shark attacks 10
deaths a year there's 100 million
sharks that are getting killed every
year the sharks aren't the ones
attacking people people are attacking
the sharks
those numbers speak for themselves body
surfing is a home invasion you know i
don't think most people looked at it
from that perspective now you're
famous as a media um you know
media mogul in effect in an online
gaming titan
when did you become a shark expert
well we had a debate some people are
equating sharks they were they're trying
to paint them as evil a couple of my
colleagues
equating them to snakes which is just
incorrect snakes are nasty vile
creatures if you read my book the best
seller i may add sharks that feeling too
i snakes jump out of bushes they
surprise you they do all this stuff they
live on land
not a shark a shark tries to mine its
own business without a shark the ocean
falls apart they the entire ecosystem
and they'll trickle right down
they're the greatest predator that ever
lived until humans and shark fin super
rides so
uh we got a debate they said if you're
so smart
write a book about it and i said you
know what i'm gonna do that
and i wrote it's actually a children's
book but it does have
profanity but it is a children's book
figure that one out
but it was the number one bestseller how
many children bought it do you have any
sense of that
did bookscan tell you no i didn't get
the demo on that
but again if you look what category is
in it was education in children's book i
didn't
hey they're going to probably learn the
f word at some point they may have
learned it a little earlier here
i i just wonder what so you go from one
career to a completely you become a
zoologist essentially overnight
and then the best-selling zoologist in
the nation
what kind of preparation education
research did it take to become a
world-renowned authority on sharks
took me two years to write that book
really explain your writing regimen
well i did a lot of research and i
looked for every pro
shark piece of propaganda that i could
find and i put it all in the book
and i one of the guys is a very
cartoonish good cartoonist
wrote child or drew child cartoons
depicting you know
fat sharks and mean sharks and angry
sharks and all sorts of things
and it turned into what uh many are
calling a
modern literature masterpiece if you
read the reviews
they don't lie you know yeah
i think you make a really good point
that amazon reviews
may be the most honest assessment of of
anything so this is our generations moby
dick it's written by dave portnoy
and it's our honor to promote this
best-selling
account of shark life dave portnoy thank
you
new respect always a pleasure respect
the sharks respect the ocean
west hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else